[Música]
sale a la luz el esperado informe por
las supuestas fiestas clandestinas en la
residencia oficial del primer ministro
del reino unido por el sión son la
investigación crítica que hubo fallas de
liderazgo y juicio en el gobierno el
mandatario pidió disculpas ante el
parlamento mientras que la oposición
instó a destituirlo tenemos reporte
desde el hombres
en el consejo de seguridad de la onu
eeuu denunció que rusia estaría
expandiendo su presencia militar en la
frontera con ucrania con la intención de
ubicar 30.000 soldados en belarús al
tiempo que la casa blanca reveló que
prepara sanciones contra miembros de la
élite rusa y sus familias en caso de una
incursión militar
la junta militar que lideró el golpe de
estado en burkina faso anunció un nuevo
presidente y promulgó una ley que regirá
al poder estatal a la espera de una
carta de transición al igual que la
cedeao la unión africana suspendió al
país hasta que se reestablezca el orden
constitucional
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos el reino
unido después de varios días de espera
salió a la luz parte del informe sobre
las supuestas fiestas clandestinas en la
residencia oficial del primer ministro
boris johnson mientras el país se
encontraba confinado por el kobe 19 la
investigación de la funcionaria su grey
concluyó que hubo fallas de liderazgo y
juicio y que estos eventos representan
un incumplimiento grave cree y admitió
que su informe tenía un alcance limitado
después de que la policía de londres
iniciara su propia investigación sobre
estas presuntas fiestas en el parlamento
la oposición instó a los diputados
conservadores a destituir al primer
ministro quien dijo que emprenderá
cambios en el funcionamiento interno de
su gobierno ya que según dijo pedir
perdón no es suficiente ampliamos esta
noticia desde londres con nuestra
periodista marcela gutiérrez
marcela muy buenas tardes para usted
cuál ha sido o cuáles han sido las
principales reacciones a la publicación
de este informe
muy buenas noches desde londres desde
luego ya había sospechas de estas
fiestas porque se filtraron muchísimos
detalles a la prensa en semanas
anteriores simplemente el informe hoy
confirma la sospecha de la población y
por lo tanto hay indignación porque
mientras la población se encontraba en
confinamiento y no podía reunirse con
sus seres queridos acudir a funerales o
despedirse de sus enfermos en downing
street se realizaban estas fiestas con
alcohol y con música y esto es lo que
confirma este informe que había exceso
de alcohol en un lugar de trabajo en la
residencia oficial de downing street-
unas fiestas o reuniones que no debieron
haber ocurrido y hoy en el congreso
desde luego la oposición ha pedido de
nueva cuenta la renuncia del primer
ministro boris johnson pero también hay
voces y voces del partido conservador de
los diputados que abiertamente algunos
de ellos han pedido la renuncia del
primer ministro
marcela se sabe que la policía también
está indagando sobre estas presuntas
fiestas pero qué es exactamente lo que
se está investigando
lo que se está investigando son 12 de 16
fiestas que pudieron haber violado las
leyes del confinamiento estas leyes y
estas reglas que se interpusieron desde
lo más alto desde el gobierno y que toda
la población tenía que cumplir y también
sabemos si ha trascendido que se va a
investigar una fiesta en particular que
ocurrió en el departamento del primer
ministro boris johnson y su esposa carla
y estas investigaciones aunque la
policía ha dicho que no habrá
actualizaciones estamos a la espera y
sobre todo el primer ministro lo ha
dicho que ahora está a la espera del
resultado de estas investigaciones
policiacas por lo tanto ha ganado tiempo
el primer ministro en nuestra crisis
política que ya dura varias semanas
desde que se conocieron los detalles de
estas supuestas o estas fiestas
clandestinas va a ser a muchas gracias
por ese reporte desde londres y
cambiamos de tema porque sigue la
escalada verbal en torno a la crisis por
la concentración de militares rusos de
la frontera ucraniana
una reunión del consejo de seguridad de
la onu el embajador ruso acusó a eeuu de
tratar de avivar la histeria de promover
un debate sobre este tema casi de forma
paralela el gobierno estadounidense
anunció que está listo para imponer
sanciones a élites rusas dentro cercanas
al kremlin si rusia envía tropas a
ucrania una medida similar a la que
planea reino unido- esto dijo la
portavoz de la casa blanca
puedo confirmar que hemos desarrollado
paquetes de sanciones específicas tanto
para las élites rusas como para sus
familiares si rusia invadiera ucrania
estos esfuerzos se llevan a cabo en
cooperación con aliados y socios las
personas que hemos identificado forman
parte o son cercanas al círculo interno
del kremlin y juegan un papel en la toma
de decisiones del gobierno o como mínimo
son cómplices del comportamiento
desestabilizador del kremlin weixing de
hater el partido del socialista antonio
costa ganó las elecciones del domingo en
portugal con mayoría absoluta algo que
permite que su tercer mandato sea mucho
más estable que los anteriores que
estuvieron marcados los bloqueos a causa
de una fuerte oposición alba santana nos
amplía
antonio costa se queda en el palacio de
belem y con mayoría absoluta contra todo
pronóstico el partido socialista repite
por tercera vez en la presidencia con
más del 40 por ciento de los votos una
mayoría absoluta
una mayoría absoluta no significa poder
absoluto no significa gobernar solo es
una responsabilidad añadida y significa
gobernar con iu para los portugueses
y para todos y toots spears y es si este
mejoría será una mejoría así que esta es
una mayoría de diálogo con todos los
partidos políticos del parlamento y con
todos los portugueses en rueda ya
publica sport y girls de su realidad
ganó tras una legislatura llena de
bloqueos de la oposición que terminó en
elecciones anticipadas por no poder
aprobar en los presupuestos las
encuestas no lo vaticinaban pero la alta
participación electoral y su gestión de
la pandemia han disparado el apoyo al
político de centroizquierda
muchos portugueses sintieron que debían
honrarlo y mostrar respeto por el
trabajo que antonio acosta hizo durante
la pandemia y creo que es una de las
razones que llevaron al partido
socialista a tener mayoría absoluta
a pesar de ser uno de los últimos países
de europa en caer en las dinámicas
ultraderechistas portugal no ha sido la
excepción con el partido llega como la
tercera fuerza política del país algo
que preocupa a muchos
no esperaba la victoria del partido
socialista pero esos son los resultados
que tenemos
el ascenso de la ultraderecha es una
vergüenza eso me preocupa
ahora con un parlamento más hostil por
el ascenso de la derecha pero más
estable por su holgada mayoría el
gobierno de costa será el encargado de
gestionar el paquete de 16 mil 600
millones de euros de la unión europea
para la recuperación por la pandemia la
junta gobernante de malí dio un plazo de
72 horas al embajador de francia para
que salga del país debido a comentarios
del gobierno francés que calificó como
hostiles e indignantes la declaración no
especificó a que comentario se refería
pero el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de francia jean yves le drían
dijo la semana pasada que la junta de
malí estaba fuera de control este es el
más reciente episodio de una tensión que
ha ido en aumento entre ambas partes
desde que el líder interino de malí
retrasó las elecciones y consolidó su
control tras el más reciente golpe de
estado
pasamos a burkina faso donde la junta
militar que lideró el golpe de estado la
semana pasada anunció que ya tiene un
nuevo presidente a través de la
televisión estatal el portavoz de la
junta dijo que el nuevo líder sería el
teniente coronel paul en rey xandao goda
mib a los militares también promulgaron
una normativa conocida como la ley
fundamental que regirá la gestión del
poder estatal a la espera de una carta
de transición y que también restablece
de manera parcial la constitución
suspendida desde el día de la toma del
poder
el mismo día la unión africana
conformada por más de 50 países del
continente suspendió a burkina faso al
igual que lo hizo la cedeao hace unos
días en un mapa turístico el movimiento
patriótico de salvaguardia y
restauración se integra de la siguiente
manera un presidente dos vicepresidentes
un coordinador de comisiones comisión el
presidente del movimiento patriótico de
salvaguardia y restauración es el
presidente de burkina faso jefe de
estado y jefe supremo de las fuerzas
armadas nacionales que es el garante de
la independencia del poder judicial en
caso de que el presidente no pueda
actuar sus facultades serán ejercidas
por el primer vice president y en su
caso por el segundo vicepresidente
citado de manera conjunta canadá eeuu el
reino unido- impusieron sanciones contra
altos funcionarios vinculados a la junta
militar en llamar justo cuando se cumple
un año del golpe este primero de febrero
las medidas están dirigidas al fiscal
general del país el presidente del
tribunal supremo y el presidente de la
comisión electoral entre otros por abuso
a los derechos humanos este mismo lunes
la depuesta lideró un sándwich y fue
acusada por presunto fraude electoral en
las elecciones de 2020 lo que se suma a
una numerosa lista de cargos que afronta
desde que fue detenida
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]